so we're finally here Secret Wars quite
literally starts on Saturday issue
number zero comes out on Free Comic Book
Day so of course those of you guys who
want to run to your local comic book
store and grab this comic to get you
started but what we're going to do in
this video and the subsequent video is
leading up to Saturday is we're going to
go over the events leading up to Secret
Wars we're going to go over time runs
out now the first part of this video is
largely going to be for people who are
looking for a refresher of sorts or for
the people who just don't really know
what's going on in order to give you
guys a solid foundation leading into
seeker wars and so in 2013 Jonathan
Hickman launched New Avengers with
volume 3 and what he did is he
introduced the incursions now when issue
number 1 of the New Avengers what
happens is Black Panther sees and earth
in the sky of the main Marvel earth
which of course as we referred to in
various videos is referred to as
earth-616 now immediately after seeing
this he's met with the hostile actions
of a woman named Black Swan and her
henchmen and so the alternate earth is
destroyed and black swan along with the
device that she used to destroy that
earth are taken into custody in Wakanda
by black panther and black panther calls
the illuminati back together again now
following this black swan explains to
Reed Richards and the Illuminati the
nature of the incursions and what she
tells us is that while the multiverse
came into existence at some previous
point in time it'll also end at some
future point on or at least it's
supposed to but what's happened is that
the time it would normally take for the
multiverse to come to an end has sped up
and so the whole reason why this would
happen was because an individual or
being named rabbu-l all was born or came
into existence on an alternate earth and
his introduction to that earth resulted
in the destruction of that alternate
earth as well as its reality and so what
this did is it created a void whereby
alternate earth so the two earths beside
it began to collide into one another and
it started a ripple effect where all
these different earths would begin to
crash into one another and when they did
that it would destroy the realities and
this is the very definition of what an
incursion is now in the event of an
incursion an eight-hour window is opened
now
during this eight hour time frame one of
the Earth's has to be destroyed
or they'll smash into each other and
both realities will be destroyed however
if one of the earths is destroyed then
the realities will just pass through
each other and no one will be harmed and
so with this knowledge what we find is
that Steve Rogers suggests using the
Infinity Gauntlet during the next
incursion in order to push the
approaching earth back into its own
place and what this would do is
basically set a standard by which they
could use the Infinity Gauntlet over and
over again if it's successful each time
there is an incursion but what happens
is that when the Illuminati track down
all of the infinity gems and they
assemble the Infinity Gauntlet when the
next incursion takes place Steve Rogers
tries to push the alternate earth back
into its reality using the or I guess
push the alternate reality back into its
place using the Infinity Gauntlet and
initially it's successful but ultimately
this results in the infinity gems
exploding or I guess shattering with the
exception of the time Jim which simply
just vanishes now in the aftermath of
this the Illuminati start discussing
using the world destroying device that
was confiscated from Black Swan as a way
to end the incursions or at least it's a
possibility as well as devising their
own methods of bringing the incursions
to and an own weapons of different
things like that now Steve Rogers
initially refuses to go along with this
and so what happens is his mind is wiped
of both the incursions event as well as
the reformation of the Illuminati by dr.
strange and so this was the reason why
during the original sin event Captain
America or Steve Rogers got all these
memories back and then as a result of
regaining these memories he basically
began to confront Tony Stark which again
led us into the video of Captain America
traveling through time now following the
next several issues after the after this
I guess the recollection of the
incursions event and the Illuminati
reforming at the hands of Steve Rogers
what we do is we pick up with the
Infinity event and what happens is the
Illuminati discover what are called the
black priests now the black priests are
basically mystics and what they do is
they use what's referred to as words of
power but all these words of power
really do is allow them to combine their
energy into a single source and then
destroy the planet that they're
currently on and so when they're seen or
when they're witness
by the Illuminati the belief is that the
black priests are basically servants of
a Booma law and that them destroying
these various alternate earth is
basically helping to speed up the
destruction of the multiverse now all of
his intentions and all the intentions of
the Illuminati basically come to a head
and issue number 21
when name of the Submariner basically
destroys an occupied earth at which
point member the Submariner is banished
from the Illuminati and the remaining
members begin to try to find their own
personal ways of bringing an end to the
incursions now while all this is taking
place in New Avengers and the actual
Avengers series proper which of course
again Jonathan Hickman is writing this
as well we basically discover everything
that we had talked about in my Hyperion
star brand and night masks videos and so
if you're interested in learning more
about those individual characters and I
would highly suggest you check those
videos out but what ends up happening
here is that again once Steve Rogers
regains his memories with regards to the
incursions event as well as the
Illuminati reforming what happens is he
simply just brands the Illuminati as
traitors and so this basically initiates
the time runs out event this is how we
begin to get into the entire time lens
out series now getting the entire runs
out proper and what we do here is we
pick up eight months after the events of
the incursions now for those of you guys
who are wondering what takes place
during this eight month period
this is basically the solo runs of
everybody during these eight months Thor
loses the ability to wield his hammer
and the female version of Thor appears
during these eight months Steve Rogers
loses his Super Soldier Serum and in
turn passes the mantle of Captain
America onto on to Falcon during these
eight months the axis event happens this
is basically how all these things begin
to come into play and so it was just a
way for model to wrap up everything with
regards to the solo series in this eight
month window and then jump into time
runs out now what we find here during
this eight month period or I guess after
this eight month period following into
the Submariner being removed from the
Illuminati was that he started his own
cabal which was composed of Thanos among
others but the problem is that while the
Cabal was brought together for the
purpose of destroying alternate earth
that would collide with earth six one
six
the Cabal began to grow out of control
and so instead of basically going
through and destroying the alternate
Earth's as they appear as part of the
incursions the Cabal would go through
they would torture people different
versions of the x-men of the Avengers on
these alternate Earth's and then they
would they'd kill them and then they
would basically destroy that earth they
basically began to relish in the idea of
raising worlds and so in an effort to
stop the Cabal name of the Submariner
actually travels to meet Doctor Doom to
basically enlist his aid now Doctor Doom
basically turns down name of the
Submariner here under the auspices that
maybe the Submariner should have come to
see him first but instead he didn't and
as a result he's basically asking Doctor
Doom to bail him out but what we find
here is that Doctor Doom actually has a
plan of his own which is the reason why
he had turned down name of the
Submariner that what had happened was
during a previous incursion on the
planet Earth with regards to the
earth-616 and an alternate reality that
Doctor Doom had captured a piece of this
alternate earth and had used it to
basically map the entire Marvel
multiverse in order to basically try to
find a way to locate the origin source
or the origin point of the occurrence
and with the help of molecule man what
his intention is is to basically travel
to this origin point and stop the
incursions and their entirety or else
figure out what caused the incursions
and gain that power for himself now in
addition to this what we also find is
that with the world being aware of the
incursions with Captain or I guess with
Steve Rogers branded the Illuminati
traitors what he does is he places the
Avengers under the control of shield in
order to use shields resources to track
down and capture the Illuminati but
basically he's been almost completely
unsuccessful so far the Illuminati have
abated him at every turn in addition to
this various members of the Avengers
have left the team for several reasons
the first reason is because some of them
just don't like hunting down their own
superheroes because for them it feels
like a very similar return to the civil
war event except this time it's Steve
Rogers leading the hunt for superheroes
as opposed to Ironman but the other
reason is because a lot of them feel
like Steve Rogers is basically lost
sight of what's going on because again
the incursions are still taking place
and so in response to Steve Rogers
trying to hunt down the Illuminati and
ignoring the incursions event what is up
happening is that former x-man sunspot
star
the multiversal Avengers when the
purpose of the multiversal Avengers
which is composed of the Avengers who
had defected from Steve Rogers this is
basically go through the entire
multiversal landscape and try to find a
way to stop the incursions but the other
half of their equation is to try to find
this middle ground try to find a way to
bring a truce between Steve Rogers
Avengers at least what's left and the
Illuminati in order for the groups to
work together and try to keep the
incursions from happening with that
being said that's part one that's what
happens in the events leading to time
runs out or I guess as part of time runs
out and so in the next video we'll focus
on what happens next and what we're
going to find is that things are going
to move relatively fast but things are
going to become infinitely more
interesting because it gets wild
especially when we get into the battle
with the beyonders which is a total
calamity for the superheroes so with
that being said I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
runningback it